The Joe Rogan experience. Um,
you and I have some shared interests clearly in the world of UFO's,
but I want to talk,
most people know of you because of Bigelow aerospace.
They know that you're this billionaire investor and you're a very successful
businessman,
but you have a deep fascination with UFO's. Yeah.
Yeah, sure.
Do. How did this all get started?
Um, back when my, uh, when I was about three years old,
which would be about 1947 and actually of may, of that year,
my grandparents had a, um, very close encounter that was dramatic.
And, um, they were taking, uh,
an afternoon evening drive in the late afternoon,
up into the mountains and coming on back down to, to Las Vegas. And they saw,
um, what appeared to be at first, an airplane on fire. And, um,
it,
the object became closer and closer to them and they pulled off to the side of
the road and at one point then it filled up the windshield and they thought they
were going to die at the last second. Uh,
it shot off and, and, uh, disappeared.
And, um,
I learned of this story when I was probably 10 years
old and cause I was three at the time. And uh,
my mother had told me the story.
So I approached my grandfather and he wouldn't talk about it now,
after all these years,
like seven years have gone by because I was intrigued with it. And, uh,
so I went to my grandmother and Shelia only would say a few words,
but she wouldn't talk. So I got the story from my mom and,
um, and they had, my grandfather had to sit on the side of the road,
they're in the car for a while to, um,
recomposed himself and uh, uh,
because they thought they were they're going to die. And uh,
and then finally he finally was able to drive on back to Las Vegas.
So that was the beginning for me.
Describe what you said. It looked like a plane on fire,
but like what was the shape of it as it got closer?
I don't recall any kind of shape that was,
that was a mother described. I don't recall that.
Um, but they just knew it wasn't a plane. They knew it was something.
So in the family, you know, in the family,
the family had an event and I lived right next door to my grandparents
and the family had an event, um, that kind of started things at that date.
For me, other personal things came later, but for the family,
that was a big deal.
So this was, you said 47,
47 and 47 was the time of the Roswell crash. 47 was a time.
There was a lot of UFO activity being observed worldwide.
And the speculation is that this to do with the nuclear bombs that were
dropped on Hiroshima and Nagasaki and all the tests that the United States had
done and Russia had done in that, there was a lot of interest in,
in obviously in that, well,
actually Russia hadn't dropped any bombs by that time. Right. It was after that,
but that there was interest in our species by
extraterrestrials cause they led, oh, these crazy are detonating nukes.
Like let's, let's go take a look out.
Right. Well, you had a so-called foo fighters during the war,
these lights that were following, uh,
bombers and the tail gunners were the ones that saw the most often of course.
And uh, and then that happens through, through the war and then,
um, and then of course Roswell, but for that was Ken, Ken Arnold,
right in about June, June ish and then July 8th,
uh, was.
As well. And there's a direct uptick though from the Trinity experiments. Right.
I think I, yeah, I gather my feeling simply is that, um,
without any kind of other,
other evidence or proof that that was a huge stomach stimulus.
Yeah. So this was around that time,
then you would heard about this as a part of family discussions. Right.
And so that sort of ignited the fire initially. Yeah.
And I started asking my friends, as I say, when I was about 10, uh, you know,
have you any, any reports in your family of anything and, and by golly,
a couple of my close friends, uh,
told me things that they had never told me before. Uh,
so you know, it wasn't,
that wasn't necessarily an exclusive event is what I'm saying.
Other people in Las Vegas had, had, uh,
seen things at close proximity as well.
Now your relationship to this is obviously something that you've carried for so
long. It's, it's been an obsession of yours for so long.
Yeah. It started with this, but what, what personal experiences, if any,
have you had.
Well,
when I was probably seven or so seven or eight,
um,
I used to have what I chocked up all my life to just being silly dreams
and I had maybe five or six of these dreams and they,
I could never make sense of them. And I would be, um,
laying in bed on my side and a typical dream, always the same,
there would be three short somebody,
somethings and, uh, kind of monk, uh, robe.
And so I couldn't see any phase, couldn't see any appendages.
And th these three whatevers were standing there and they,
they were not too far from my eye level as far as the Heights and so forth. So.
There's like child size. Yeah.
Yeah. And, uh, so there was nothing in the, I was an avid comic book reader,
but there was nothing in the, in the whole genre of comic books that, uh,
related to that or movies. And, uh,
we didn't have television in Las Vegas till 53 or 54. And even after that,
it was terrible broadcasting, uh, you know, at first,
but so it made no sense to me. And, um,
so over my lifetime, I never mentioned it to anybody.
Including my wife. You know,
it's funny how you keep things a secret and, uh, just kind of for no,
no good reason. Um, maybe I was be embarrassed to,
to talk about it, but I finally thought, well, you know,
maybe it was just dreams. Maybe it was something else. And, uh,
so that was a first event personally, that I had, uh,
at that time was in the subject.
And you start to connect the idea of these tiny people or human,
like things with extraterrestrials.
Well, years later, um,
when I began to start my process as a researcher
and as a student, um, in the subject, uh,
and began to talk with people who are,
who made it their business to be experts in abductions. And, uh,
the more I got into the field and, uh, uh,
sat writing out questions, uh, for the researcher,
for the therapist who would be asking the questions and,
and I'd be sitting there and watching the process. And just over time,
I thought, well, you know, maybe there was something more to it, but, um,
uh, I'm better off not knowing anything.
So I'll just block it off and forget about it.
Yeah. We talked last night about John Mac a little bit, uh, the Harvard, uh,
great guy. Yeah.
And he did a lot of these sort of a
hypnotic regression sessions with people where they describe very similar
scenarios, all well.
Yeah, multiple tools at different situations. Uh, uh,
the adduction phenomena was, was, um, uh,
very proliferate and in the population has, seemed like, uh,
even we did a survey called the Roper poll and, uh,
we repeated it three times so that the margin of error was really reduced to
like one, one and a half percent. And, um,
abduction researchers came up with the 10 questions. And, uh,
so they, we distributed that, um,
uh, and the,
the conclusion was a fairly relatively sizable percentage of the population had
some kind of experience as according to them,
according to the researchers and according to the poll, um,
I am not qualified to speak to the accuracy of whether the questions were
that relevant to the conclusions or not. Uh, but that's what they said.
And, uh, so,
and I had in my own research found people that I put them through a
regression. I not personally,
but I found a hypnotherapist that could do that.
And I found a number of people just pure they're scattered around, uh,
maybe somebody in my own staff. And, uh, they would come up with,
with these, these stories and these events.
One of the criticisms of John Mack and hypnotic regression in general,
is that the idea that you can put, um,
the idea that you can put a memory into someone's head,
that you could suggest things and you could create false memories.
And this was something that I've read in the criticism of his work,
that this style of hypnotic regression and bringing up these
very specific scenarios to a bunch of different people,
you can sort of help create, especially in, uh,
people that are easily influenced or PR people,
people that are open to suggestion,
you could put these false memories in their head. And so, you know,
especially when you're dealing with something as fantastic as a UFO or
alien abduction or visitation, or.
Oh, that's definitely possible. Um, there's also something called screen memory,
but dealing with the first, the power suggestion, that's absolutely true.
But my experience was with a different hypnotherapists.
They went out of their way. Uh, in fact,
to see maybe if they did make a suggestion, it was just the opposite.
They might say, okay, you're on board, this craft, um, you know, where's the,
uh, where's the lighting coming from? Is it coming from the corner or of the,
of the room that you're in while there were no corners and they'd be corrected
right away by the person being
given have happened sized. And, uh,
so they went just the opposite direction on purpose to make,
make suggestions,
to maybe coax the person to come that direction and they wouldn't do it.
The person wouldn't do it. And a screen memory is different.
Supposedly if somebody has a very close encounter, um,
with supposedly somebody that's that CT, uh,
you leave that at that, uh,
the memory turns out to be entirely different and that's put into you
consciously,
and you recall something entirely different than what actually happened.
Maybe you, you saw deer to deer on the road or something of that sort,
uh, or maybe there were owls or whatever. So, um, that's,
what's purported.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes, save on data costs all for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Geri on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan.